going back to curiosity which is more
crucial and interesting topic but a
reluctant or maybe not fully developed
subject for whatever reason or the
reverse a fascinating person but a topic
that's maybe more vague and a little bit
too broad well we don't make films about
topics we're very careful not to come up
with a topic and then try to back into
it but it's it's important to have
subject matter that is rich and has
depth that it could be full of surprises
and twists and turns but it doesn't
matter if you have that an in-depth
topic if you don't have amazing
characters to take you on the journey so
really we look for both we look for a
subject matter that hasn't been picked
over so many times that people think
that they knows that much about it and
you also need these great storytellers
which is part of our casting process is
to find those who can articulate a
journey or can change over the course of
a film and can bring a subject matter to
life I think it would be almost a Venn
diagram actually when you put it that
way
which is if there are both we make a
movie about it and it's it's hard to
have both it's unusual which is why we
make a film every couple of years or so
because they don't come along every
minute how far into the process of the
film do you know if the subject is
working I know you talked about how do I
think with boys of baraka that you had
one subject that seemed more reluctant
but that person was so fascinating that
you really wanted to keep up with it
yeah okay so and I'm sure that was a
painful mistake cause you probably
really wanted that person in the very
much to one the one that got away we
have learned over a long career that
reluctant subjects are no subjects at
all a reluctant subject it only exists
in your mind he or she will never
participate or allow you the access that
we need in order to make a satisfying
film so we detect very early on by doing
test shoots and allowing people to
saying listen let's come into your house
let's shoot a little bit see how it
feels for both of us because how
reluctant or subject that's too shy
camera shy or too self-conscious
probably won't get over that and so you
have to move on and it can be very very
painful and we don't really make that
mistake too much anymore on this film we
did film several people before we
settled on our final three and one was a
reluctant subject that we spent a couple
of too many days on maybe thinking that
he might come around but he did not so
you keep mate you keep making them
stumbles hopefully you spend less and
less time on the reluctant subject every
film
you